appelle les questions au gouvernement la
parole est à madame virginie duby muller
ce premier ministre nos policiers sont
contraints d'aller dans la rue pour
attirer votre attention
il était en détresse ils sont désormais
en colère les jours passent leur
mobilisation n'a pas faibli et ce dans
toute la france il commence même à être
rejoints par les pompiers du jamais vu
car le constat est sans appel
ils sont attaqués par des délinquants
insuffisamment puni qui se sentent
intouchables et ils travaillent dans des
conditions dégradées l'exemple annemasse
ou le commissariat contre 116 policiers
niveau le plus bas depuis 15 ans alors
que la spécificité transfrontalières en
nécessiterait 130 les postes ne sont pas
pourvus en raison du coût de la vie et
ce n'est pas faute de vous avoir proposé
une prime de vie chère pour les
fonctionnaires de cette zone
nous venons de découvrir vos
propositions tardive
révélée dans la presse aujourd'hui bien
des revendications des policiers n'ont
pas été prises en compte
ils réclament en effet un
assouplissement des règles de légitime
défense
le rétablissement des peines planchers
pour les agresseurs de membres de forces
de l'ordre que nous avions créé et que
vous êtes empressé de supprimer alors
oui avec vous c'est vrai le sujet est
miné vous allez comme toujours nous
renvoyer vers le quinquennat de nicolas
sarkozy et même celui de jacques chirac
avant lui en réinterprétant les chiffres
quand on sait pas quoi répondre c'est
toujours plus facile d'accuser son
voisin le problème c'est qu'entre mai
et aujourd'hui l'ensemble des
indicateurs en matière d'insécurité est
en hausse notamment 14% sur les vols
simples 12% d'atteintes volontaires à
l'intégrité physique et d'autre et la
seule courbe qui s'inverse sous votre
quinquennat c'est celle de la population
carcérale
quelle réussite entre 2007 et 2012 nous
avions mis en place plusieurs réformes
pour moderniser et optimiser l'action de
la police accompagnée d'une réforme
pénale ambitieuse pour nous une
politique de sécurité qui ne reposerait
que sur les effectifs seraient
particulièrement inefficace monsieur le
premier ministre le président hollande
rencontrent aujourd'hui les
représentants de la police comme
toujours vous expliquer être dans une
démarche de dialogue
nous préférerions aujourd'hui enfin vous
voir dans une démarche d'action
merci la parole est à monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur bernard cazenave
madame la députée vous indiquer qu une
politique efficace en matière de
sécurité ne peut pas se réduire à la
création d'emplois j'imagine que c'est
pour cette raison que vous avez soutenu
un gouvernement qui a supprimé 13 milles
au cours des cinq dernières années
vous venez d'expliquer qu' une bonne
politique de sécurité est une politique
qui n'attache pas d'importance aux
moyens qu'on alloue aux forces de
l'ordre j'imagine que c'est pour cette
raison que vous avez soutenu un
gouvernement qui a diminué de 15%
les crédits fonctionnement de la police
et de la gendarmerie
alors vous vous interrogez madame sur la
question de savoir quel est le plan
d'action qui est le no d'abord je veux
vous rappeler ce que nous avons déjà
fait je vous dirai ce que ce sur quoi
nous nous orientons au terme du dialogue
que nous avons engagées avec les
policiers d'abord nous avons recréé des
emplois nous avons créé 9000 emplois au
sein de la police et de la gendarmerie
et 7 9 mille emplois ont permis de
rehausser pts et significativement le
niveau des effectifs dans les
territoires où il y avait des déficits
considérables de policier de gendarme ça
a été le cas par exemple en seine saint
denis où je suis allé annoncer la
création de 300 emplois supplémentaires
ces deux le cas dans l'essonne où je
suis allé annoncer la création de 200
emplois supplémentaires
vous me dites qu'il ya des territoires
où effectivement on n'a pas encore
rattrapé l'effet de la suppression
d'effectifs bien entendu parce que quand
on supprime 13 mille emplois on le fait
très vite et il est très long de
rattraper la totalité des effectifs
supprimés
nous avons créé des moyens
supplémentaires pour la police et la
gendarmerie je rappelle que nous avons
ré équiper tous les psig et toutes les
brigades anti criminalité de la police
et de la gendarmerie
j'annoncerai tout à l'heure aux côtés du
président de la république un ensemble
de mesures dont on ne sait rien donc
avant de les critiquer attendait qu'elle
soit annoncée
et ces mesures je vous en donne quelques
orientations renforcer le plan
d'équipement déterminer les tâches
indues à alléger et faire en sorte que
nous puissions répondre à un certain
nombre d'attentes notamment concernant
la